[Music]
our ocean nearly 4 billion years old
self-regulating self-healing the source
of all life on earth yet it is in danger
threatened by a truly global problem
marine pollution from the remotest
Pacific Islands to the bottom of the
Mariana Trench to right here on the
beaches of Malta oil spills
[Music]
ship emissions industrial waste and
pesticides all poisoned vast stretches
of water 10 million tons of litter are
dumped in the sea every year 400 kilos
per second by 2050 our ocean could
contain more plastic than fish pollution
is destroying marine life plastics alone
are killing 1 million seabirds and
100,000 marine mammals a year
microplastics threatened to unhinge
whole ecosystems these problems don't
stop at sea contaminants such as mercury
accumulate in the food chain affecting
the health of millions of people with
80% marine litter coming from land
sources everyone is responsible but the
solution is at hand and it offers a
great opportunity marine pollution costs
billions switching to circular economies
could make up for this loss and more
with environmental economic and social
gains for all so to reverse the trend of
ever-increasing marine pollution how can
we minimize waste how can we prevent
plastics from regency how can we stop
marine pollution
[Music]